here's a local news report about a
teacher who went to shall we say extreme
lengths to protect herself
from her son when she thought that he
might have had covet listen
a local teacher is accused of putting
her son in the trunk of her car while
she got tested for covid according to
the district attorney's office she said
he tested positive and she was trying to
isolate him and now we're learning that
that woman is a teacher at a local
school district our bill barajas is live
now in northwest harris county with the
latest bill
well scifir isd tells us she is a 41
year old sarah beam a cypress falls high
school teacher according to court
records that teacher went to prison
stadium's testing site on monday with
her son in the trunk of her car because
he had tested positive for covet and she
did not want to be exposed so she has
been now charged with endangering a
child
well when i first heard this uh story i
know it doesn't doesn't surprise me that
it's a teacher i probably could have
told you that
i just you hear these kinds of stories
and it sends chills down my spine when i
think about the kids
who are in who are in these households
governed by these coveted psychopaths
imagine i mean this poor kid imagine
what he's had to endure but seriously
imagine what he's had to endure for the
last two to three years
and it always goes back like we've been
talking about you know it goes back to
yeah this is uh germaphobia and and all
of those kinds of things
super paranoid people
um
and uh
many of them have just been their brains
have been broken by the media the media
by the way you know condemning this
woman but of course it's partly their
fault they're they're partly responsible
for this kind of thing they have
intentionally broken everybody's brains
and then and then this is what happens
as a result
so all of that factors into it but then
also there is this
this
obsessive self-centeredness
from these parents
who are not primarily concerned
with the safety of their own kids
they're just thinking about themselves
and they will inflict any torture on
their children to keep themselves safe
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated